ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้า
สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนน้องก็มาเจอกับเรา 2 คนเหมือน
เดิมในวีดีโอระดับบีกินเนอร์ม้าขาลูกค้า
วันนี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วันจันทร์ค่ะ
วันจันทร์ที่เท่าไหร่คะวันจันทร์ที่ 27
เดือนอะไรคะเดือนธันวาคมเดือนธันวาคมเป็น
เดือนที่เท่าไหร่คะ 12 ค่ะ
ปีพศอะไรคะ
2564 ปีค.ศอะไรคะของ 021
แล้วเมื่อวานนี้อ่าวันอะไรเมื่อวานนี้วัน
อาทิตย์ค่ะวันอาทิตย์ที่เท่าไหร่คะวัน
อาทิตย์ที่ 26 เดือน
เดือน
ธันวาคมเป็นเดือนที่เท่าไหร่คะเป็นเดือน
ที่ 12 ค่ะปีพต
2564 ปีคศ 2  021 แล้วพรุ่งนี้วันอะไร
พรุ่งนี้วันอังคารค่ะวันอังคารที่เท่า
ไหร่คะวันอังคารที่ 28 เดือน
ธันวาคมเป็นเดือนที่เท่าไหร่คะ 12 ค่ะปีพ
ต
2564 ปีคศ 2  021 หรือใส่แล้วแล้วตอนนี้
เวลากี่โมงแล้วคะคุณฟ้าแต่ตอนนี้ 14:00 น
14:00 นงกี่นาทีคะ
47 นาทีค่ะบ่าย 2 โมง 47 นาทีน้องก็เป็น
ตอนกลางวันต้องขอรางวัลก็กลางวันโอเคผู้
หญิงสบายดีไหมคะสบายดีค่ะแข็งแรงครูฟ้าคะ
สบายดีไหมคะสบายดี
ดูหน้าเข้าใจ
คิดว่าครูฟ้าเนี่ยต้องกินอิ่มเคยสบายดี
ใช่กินเยอะ
ครูฟ้าวเลยค่ะครูกัซกินอาหารสมัยอาหารไทย
อาหารอิตาลีอาหารฝรั่งเนี่ยครูฟ้าชอบกิน
อาหารรสอะไรอ่ะเอ้าตัวอย่างที่ไทยใช่ไหม
และก็จะมีเวลากินอาหารก็
เค็มเปรี้ยวเผ็ดอย่างเงี้ยเป็นรสชาติของ
อาหาร
ก็จะมีไม่กี่รสชาติใช่ใช่ไหมก็อยากมีอ่ะ
อย่างถ้าเป็นเกลือหรอมองเห็นนะคะหลีกแสง
ตรงไหนคะเนี่ยเกลือนะเนี่ยเกลือชาติเป็น
ยังไงคะรสเค็มค่ะเวลามีเทเกลือใช่ไหมแล้ว
ก็กินอ้ะหืออือเค็ม
เตือนเกี่ยวรสเค็ม
ออกอุบายชอบค่ะ
ชอบเต็มแล้วถ้าเป็นอันนี้ล่ะคะสีเขาขาวๆ
เหมือนเกลือไม่แต่ไม่ใช่เกลืองน้ำตาลน้อง
จาเนี่ยมีรถอะไรคะเวลากิน
รสเค็มรสหวาน
กว่าหวานก็ใส่น้ำตาลเนี่ย
รักอาแล้วอันนี้อะไรคะคือฟ้า
มะนาวค่ะมะนาวเนี่ยเวลากินรสอะไรคะเวลา
กินมะนาวรสเปรี้ยวตัดเปียวใช่ไหมเตรียม
เงียบเอา
อันนี้อะไรคะโอ้อันนี้พริกขานี้คุณติ๊ก
แล้วนะคะพริกเขียวพริกเนี่ยเวลากินรสอะไร
คะเวลากินรดพิตต์
เผ็ดสมัยเหมือนกันชบี
เค็ม
หวาน
เปรี้ยวเผ็ดให้คนไทยพูดยังไงนะ
อ่อนก็ผัดแกงทอดหวานเปรี้ยวหวานสิบกว่า
เปรี้ยวหวานเผ็ดเค็มๆ
ท่องเที่ยว
หวานนกน้ำตาลเห็ดแล้วก็เค็ม
ครูป๊าชอบรสเค็มสมัยเกลือเนี่ย M ปูปลา
ชอบรสเค็มคู่หญิงมากชอบรวยอะไรผู้หญิงชอบ
หวานจะเปรี้ยว 2 อย่างได้มั้ยหวานกับ
เปรี้ยวได้ๆๆนายแล้วครูฟ้าไม่ชอบแบบเอ้ย
ไม่ชอบกินอ่ะรสอะไร
รูฟาไม่ชอบรสหวานเนี่ยหรออ๋อรสหวานใช่
มั้ยน้ำตาลนี่ชอบรสหวานถ้าเป็นอาหารนะไม่
ชอบรสหวานค่ะเป็นขนม
โอเคคุกกี้อะไรเงี้ยโอเค
หวานก็ได้ได้แต่ถ้าอาหารเนี่ยอาหารที่มี
รสหวานก็ใส่น้ำตาลน้ำตาลเยอะๆเขาไม่ชอบ
มันก็โอเคแล้วก็มี 4 ผู้หญิงไม่ชอบรสอะไร
คะครูหญิงไว้สร้อบรสเค็ม
ทำไมไม่อร่อย
อร่อยมาก
ใช่กูฟ้าชอบผู้หญิงไม่ซ้อนก็จะมีรส
เปรี้ยวเหมือนมะนาวมะนาวนั่งรถเรี่ยว
เที่ยวเห็ด
พริกนะเค็มจากเกลือแล้วก็หวานจากน้ำตาล
หรอวันนี้เนี่ยเราก็จะมีอาหารนะอาหารนะคะ
แล้วก็จะไปดูว่ามันมีรสชาติอะไรบ้าง
เดี๋ยวถึงจะแชร์สกรีนให้นักเรียนดูได้ค่ะ
ครูหญิง
รอสักครู่นะคะ
ว่า
อาหารอะไรทำไมเวลากินมีรสอะไรอ่ะมาเลย
เนี้ยแล้วก็จะมี
มะนาว
มะนาวแล้วครั้งอะไรคะภูฟ้า
มะม่วงค่ะมะม่วงมะนาวกับมะม่วงอันไหนที่
กินแล้วเนี่ยมีรสเปรี้ยวเปรี้ยว
มะนาวค่ะมะนาวใช่ไหมข้างบนใช่ไหมแล้วแม่
นาวินแล้วเปรี้ยวอาแจ็กซ์แล้วถ้ามะม่วง
ล่ะ
แล้วมุขสุดเนี่ยดีนะมะม่วงสุกไม่เปรี้ยว
ค่ะแล้วสุกหวานมีรสหวาน
รูปต่อไปนะคะมีอันนี้อะไรคะคุณฟ้าอาชานม
ไข่มุกค่ะแล้วอีกรูปนึงล่ะคะละก็คือน้ำ
ปลาค่ะชานมไข่มุกกับน้ำปลาค่ะไหนมีรสเค็ม
ทำไมเนาะเหมือนเกลือ
น้ำปลาค่ะน้องปลาเพราะว่านักเรียนเนี่ย
นักเรียนทำอาหารแล้วก็อยากให้เค็มนัก
เรียนเนี่ยใส่เกลือใส่แต่คนไทยทำอาหาร
แล้วไม่เค็ม
คนไทยใส่ใส่น้ำปลาน้ำปลาใช่ไหมลูกนี้นะ
นักเรียนบางคนไม่ชอบ
น้ำปลาหลังนั้นไม่ชอบเค็มหรอว่าน้ำปลา
เค็มเกลือเค็มมันไม่ชอบเค็มหรอนักเรียน
ถ้าชอบน้ำปลาทำไมอ้ะมันมีกลิ่นใช่มั้ย
เหม็นนักเรียนบอกเดช
ไปเอาน้ำตาแต่กินอ่ะอร่อยๆ
หรือแต่ชานมไข่มุกหวานเนาะ
ชานมไข่มุกในหวานนอกครูฟ้าต.กุดโชว์มากนะ
แตกหวานมากน้ำตาลเยอะเลยชานมไข่มุกเนี่ย
หวานเพราะว่าใส่น้ำตาลสมัยน้ำตาลเนี่ย
เวลาใส่ลงไปแล้วก็กินอย่างมึงหวานนะคะ
ลูกต่อไปค่ะ
ข้างบนอะไรคะข้างบนน้ำผึ้งค่ะข้างล่าง
ข้างล่างชีสจ้าน้ำผึ้งจับ Cheese อันที่
ไหนมีรสหวานนักเรียนจำได้ไม่หวานติ๊กต๊อก
ติ๊กต๊อกติ๊กต๊อก
หวาน
มีรสหวานต้องคือน้ำผึ้งค่ะน้ำผึ้งใช้เวลา
เรากินน้ำผึ้งแบบ
หวานเหมือนน้ำตาล
แล้วชี้สาคูฟ้าเวลากินชีสรสอะไรเวลากิน
ชีสภูฟ้าจำได้ว่างเค็มๆเหมือนเกลือมีเห็น
เค็มเรือ
Mac  Cheese เพราะว่าชีสแหนะเค็ม
ชอบค่ะเพราะว่ากูปลาชอบเค็ม
ผู้หญิงก็จะกินได้แค่น้ำผึ้งใช่ไหมชาย
อ่ะต่อไปค่ะ
ข้างบนเนี่ยแอปเปิ้ลเขียวสีเขียวอยู่ข้าง
ล่างเนี่ยสาลี่หน้าแอ็ปเปิ้ลเขียวกับ
สาลี่อันไหนมีรส
เปรี้ยวเนี่ยจำเปรี้ยวเนี่ยมันเปรี้ยว
เปรี้ยวเปรี้ยวๆเหมือนมะนาวเปรี้ยวอะไรคะ
เกี่ยวค่ะรีวิวสีเขียวๆไงแล้วสาลีล่ะ
สาลี่รถอะไร
สาลี่คิดว่าน่าจะหวาน
หวานหวานเหมือนน้ำตาลน้องเหมือนลาย
ฟ้าชอบอันไหนคะแอปเปิ้ลเขียวเปรี้ยวหรือ
ว่าสาลี่เนี่ยหว่าหวาน
ไม่ชอบสาลี่
ไม่ได้ชอบแอปเปิ้ลที่เดียวผู้หญิงล่ะคะ
ผู้หญิงสองอย่างโอเคฮะโอเคค่ะเปรี้ยวโอเค
หวานโอเค
น้ำรูปต่อไปค่ะข้างบนเนี่ยเป็นมันฝรั่ง
ทอดหรือว่าโต้ชิพนะคะคือร่างเนี่ยขิงนะ
ขิงนะคะครูฟ้าคะมันฝรั่งทอดกับขิงอันไหน
เวลากินแล้วเนี่ยมีรสเผ็ด
H เหมือนพริก
ใช่ไหมคะกับกิ๋งสอบว่าเออขิงหะขิงเนาะ
เห็ดเนาะหัวขิงเห็ดมากๆ
ไม่ชอบกินขิง
คู่ฟ้าไม่ชอบไม่ชอบเผ็ดเหรอคะไม่ชอบเผ็ด
จากขิงนะไม่ชอบกินแต่ถ้าพริกอ้ะพริกเผ็ด
ฮะโอเคก็โอเคโอเคๆแล้วมันฝรั่งทอดน่ะรส
อะไรมันฝรั่งทอดรสเค็มค่ะเค็มเหมือนเป็น
ไปไงใช่ไหมชิม
อันนี้ดีกว่า
อะไรอันแรกนะคะเป็น seiki รุ
ว่า soy  Sauce นะคะอีกอันนึงก็คือเป็น
พริกไทยเนาะลืมเรื่องครูฟ้าคะซีอิ๊วกับ
พริกไทยอันไหนมีรสเค็ม
เข็ม
หิวค่ะหิว M เหมือนเหมือนกับเกลือ
เกม
แล้วพริกไทยล่ะพริกไทยรสอะไรพริกไทยรส
เผ็ดขนาดเดี๋ยว
เผ็ด R ค่าเล่าเรียนอยากกินเผ็ดกินพริก
ไทยได้เลยจ่ายทะเลบอกว่าโอ้พริเผ็ดไม่
โอเคพริกไทยนะคะไม่ใช่ใช้ค่ะก็โอเคโอเคนะ
พริกไทยจ่ายใส่ๆอ้ะเรื่องต่อไปนะคะก็จะมี
อันแรกเนี่ยเป็นเพรทเซล
pretzel อีกอันนึงอีกร่วมหนึ่งอะไรคะ
เป็นช็อกโกแลต
หรอครูฟ้าคะเพรทเซลกับช็อกโกแลตอันไหนมี
รส
หวาน
ว่าคิดว่าช็อกโกแลตค่ะช็อกโกแลตหวาน
หวานมากเย้แตกช็อกโกแลตใส่รับเพรทเซลเวลา
กินเพรทเซลรถอะไรเข้มเข้ม
เอาเข็มฟ้าชอบไหม
ชอบ sever มากมากินเซ็นเซอร์บ่อยๆนะกิน
ทุกวัน Bright กินกินวันจันทร์วันอังคาร
วันพุธพฤหัสวันศุกร์วันเสาร์วันอาทิตย์
วันจันทร์วันอังคารกินทุกวัน
อร่อยวันนี้นักเรียนรู้จักไหมเนี่ย
อันแรกนะคะเป็นปลาคือจะต้องวาดรูปนะคะ
เป็นปลาปลาปลา
นะคะปลาแล้วก็ใส่เกลือไม่มีเกลือแล้วก็
ใส่แล้วก็มีพระอาทิตย์นะคะแล้วก็ตากแดด
น้องตากแดด 1 วันนะ 1 วัน 2 วัน 3 วันคะ
เราเรียกว่าปลาเค็มปลาเค็มโมแล้วก็อีกรูป
นึงก็คือ grape รถหรือว่าภาษาไทยเรียกว่า
อะไรคะผู้หญิงอะไรอ่ะเป็นส้มเรดฟุตส้ม
เเรพรุจ
ภาษาไทยชายครูฟ้าอะไรคะมีรสเปรี้ยว
รสเปรี้ยว
ส้มเกรฟฟุ๊ตค่ะทรายน้ำส้มเกรปฟูจะเปรี้ยว
แล้วปลาเค็มเหรอคะปลาเค็มรสอะไรปลาเค็มก็
รสเค็มใช่มั้ยคิมว่าปลาเค็มก็ใส่เกลือไม่
มีเกลือก็ต้องเก็บป้าเข็มให้เห้ยอ้ะก้าว
ไปค่ะ
ข้างบนเป็นอะไรคะคุณฟ้าหัวหอม
โอกาสเฮี้ยวมี
ผู้ป๋าบอกกูว่าเข้าใจกระเทียมแต่ปากพูด
หัวของสายอยากกินปของกระเทียมมาทีเรียม
หรอคะ
Raspberry มั้ยๆ Raspberry
ค้ากระเทียมกับ Raspberry
อันไหนที่มีรสเผ็ด
เผ็ด
กระเทียมค่ะชัดกระเทียมทีมแล้วนะหรอกนะ
พริก
[เพลง]
แล้วรักเบอร์รี่กินแล้วรสชาติยังไงคะผู้
หญิง
เอาหัครูป่า
ฟรีเที่ยวมากเลยได้เที่ยวเนาะเปรี้ยว
เหมือนมะนาวเปรี้ยวค่ะราสเบอร์รี่เปรี้ยว
น้อต่อ
เลยค่ะ
สตรอเบอรี่ฟันชอบใช่มั้ยใช่หาสตรอเบอรี่
ก็โอเคอร่อย Pop ค้อน
อ๋ออ๋อ
สตรอเบอรี่กับป๊อปคอร์นอันไหนมีรสเค็ม
ป้อมคอนค่ะอยากป๊อปคอร์นนี้นะคะดูแบบนี้
ใช่ไหมป๊อปคอร์นสีเขาขาวๆเนี่ยเข็ม
แล้วโทษเอาเบอร์รี่อ่ะรสอะไร
รักต่างตรอเบอรี่ให้ประเทศไทย
เที่ยวค่ะไก่สตอเบอรี่ที่ไทย
เหมือนมะนาวเปรี้ยวแต่
สตรอเบอรี่ประเทศนักเรียน
ไม่รู้เนาะก็ไม่รู้ว่าแต่น่าจะหวานเนาะใจ
ใส่เหลือเชื่อ Sorry กินสมัยมีสตอเบอรี่
ประเทศไทย
เปรี้ยว
สตอเบอรี่การญี่ปุ่นเกาหลียุโรปอเมริกา
ถุง
กว่า
เนาะตายหรือรูปนะคะได้ค่ะเอาง่ายๆ
อะไหล่เอานี้ดีกว่าค่ะ
อ่ะโอเคข้างบนอะไรคะครูฟ้ามากะรองค่ะแล้ว
ข้างล่าง
หัวหอม
หัวหอมเนาะมาการองกับหัวหอมอันไหนมีรส
หวาน
หวานมาตลอ่งชันคุณยายบางกรองแหละมาเกราะ
ฮือฮือ
หวานๆ
หัวหอมราคะรถอยู่ค่ะ
ละกินหอยแบบเผ็ดน้องมีรสเผ็ดสมัยขาแล้วก็
ดีก็เป็นรสชาตินะของอาหารสมัยก็จะมี
เปรี้ยวเปรี้ยวจากมะนาว
เพชรคิดคลิกบิ๊กเค็มเค็มเกลือแล้วก็หวาน
น้ำตาลน้ำตาลทรายรี่เปรี้ยวเผ็ดเค็มหวาน
ครูฟ้าชอบรสเค็มครูหญิงชอบเปรี้ยวกับหวาน
แล้วนักเรียนชอบรสอะไรกองคะคอมเม้นท์บอก
เราได้นะคะนี้ค่ะอ่าโอเคทีให้ตกไม่ชอบ
อะไรเนาะเพราะบอกนายกได้นะโอเคค่ะวันนี้
เราสองคนก็ต้องไปก่อนนะแล้วเจอกันวีดีโอ
หน้านะคะบ๊ายบายสวัสดีค่ะอ่ะ